отже 14:00
день
Я так розумію що ми працюємо наживо тому
що мені підтвердити
так гаразд А ще раз добрий день раді
вітати вас на спільному вебінарі
Міністерства освіти та науки України
проекту search а також українського
інституту розвитку освіти Сьогодні ми
презентуємо діагностичний тест новий
інструмент для вчителя з допомогою якого
можна виявити та надолужити навчальні
втрати у знаннях та вміннях учнів та
учениць Мене звати Ольга стридюк Я
експертка з оцінювання якості середньої
освіти проекту search сьогодні
модеруватиму цю зустріч ми працюватимемо
годину Я коротко представлю нашу ідею та
суть діагностичних тестів далі я передам
слово нашим авторам які детальніше ще
раз розкажуть про ідею тесту
представлять структуру так З яких частин
він складається А також коли і як саме
його можна використовувати також
попросимо наших авторів детальніше
розглянути ті навчальні теми які
закладені і вдалося у нашому тесті
продемонструвати після того колеги з
української інституту розвитку освіти
покажуть а також розкажуть як вчитель
безпосередньо може організувати і
провести тестування з допомогою
нашого онлайн-ресурсу всеукраїнської
школи онлайн
Загалом ми маємо працювати годину якщо
після усіх презентацій у вас
залишатимуться питання То ми матимемо
час або на них відповісти
отже
яка ідея розробки такого інструменту і
звідки вона з'явилася
інструмент розробився як відповідь на
виклики з якими На жаль зустрілися наша
країна спочатку в умовах пандемії коли
ми перейшли із очного на дистанційний
процес а потім погіршення стали все
яскравішими так у нас розпочалася ця
війна і ті виклики з якими зіткнулися
українські школярів вчителі також їхні
батьки насправді є надзвичайно потужними
і на них потрібно було реагувати
основним викликом на нашу думку і далі
залишається обмежений доступ до
стабільного такого звиклого очного
освітнього процесу до якого Ми звикли
Разом з тим ці виклики спричинили
прогалине у результатах навчання учнів
та учениць ми можемо по-різному
оцінювати ці виклики наскільки глибокими
вони є але вони є і коли ми почали
шукати способи мінімізації таких
викликів то
поза нашою увагою не міг пройти той
нестабільний освітній процес триває
більше двох років на якомусь етапі ми
взагалі задалися собі запитання чи
достатньо в учнів та вмінь аби
продовжувати навчання на наступному
рівні середньої освіти тому що хтось
втратив два роки наприклад третя та
четвертий клас початкової школи а хтось
можливо не втратив але недостатньо
ґрунтовно опрацьовував певні матеріали
чи навчальні теми у 5-6 класі із знаєш з
цих наших роздумів ви
народилися ідея розробити діагностичний
інструмент який би вимірював навчальні
втрати
на певних рівнях освіти або на певних
циклах освіти власне тому сьогодні ми
будемо презентувати вам діагностичні
тести які можна застосовувати у 5-7 та
дев'ятому класі реєструючись на цей
вебінар ви задавали запитання одне з них
звучало Таким чином чи тести для всіх
учнів і усіх класів одразу відповім на
це питання що все ж таки ні заклик тести
побудовані за таким циклічним у
циклічний спосіб тобто
перший тест для учнів на початку 5 класу
ми пропонуємо для зациклу початкової
школи тобто за цикл 3-4 класу другий
тест - це тест за перший цикл базової
середньої школи за курс 5 та 6 класу
пропонуємо для семикласників а також
тести за цикл 7 та 8 класу за другий
цикл базової середньої освіти Разом з
тим такі тести можна використовувати не
лише в 5-7 та дев'ятому класі але й
наприкінці четвертого шостого та 8 класу
тобто
умовно приблизно в квітні місяці
вчителі
4-6 та 8 класу можуть використати такі
тести аби подивитися як учні
засвоїли певні навчальні теми на
дворічних циклах такого навчання
Разом з тим На жаль ми маємо таку
ситуацію що частина дітей
перебували за кордон І лише за кордоном
І лише зараз повертається до своїх
класів чи до своїх закладів всеосвіти а
можливо вони не повертаються до своїх
закладів освіти натомість переходять у
інші
учитель який
дитину також може використати ці тести
аби зрозуміти На якому рівні перебуває
учень чи учениця яка буквально
прийшла до її класу Але знову ж таки ми
пам'ятаємо про цикли так тобто за цикл
3-4 класу цикл 5-6 класу і цикл 7 та 8
класу як загалом працює такий Інструмент
я дозволю собі пошарити лише один
лише один слайд який представлений у нас
на
вашо Так є загальна логіка і розуміння
того як би мав працювати тест І в що ми
в нього вкладали Отже наша діагностичні
тести - це не просто набір тестових
завдань які ми пропонуємо вчителю для
того щоб він оцінив ймовірні навчальні
втрати ми пропонуємо спочатку
провести первинний діагностичне
тестування тобто пропонуємо завдання для
первинного тесту далі по закінченню
тестування і учень і вчитель отримує
інформацію про те як учні склали тест
інформація - це не оцінка інформація -
це рівень початковий достатній
базовий або високий і відповідно до цих
рівнів Куди потрапив той чи інший учень
учитель разом з цими учнями може
планувати роботу над помилками яких було
допущено Кожен учень є за результатами
первинної діагностики звіт де вказана
інформація про неправильну виконане
особливо важливо учень отримує також
інформацію про відео про можливо
роботу з тестовими іншими матеріалами
про параграфи в конкретних підручниках з
якими я одну варто попрацювати ми собі
орієнтуємося що на таку підготовку
потрібно місяць півтори після того як
учень і вчителі попрацюють ми пропонуємо
тести для вторинного діагностичного
тестування поки що на сайті виши
оприлюднено лише
щоби учням буквально на другий день не
хотіло пройти і вторинного
ділепностичного тестування але і
первинне і вторинне
Чого після проходження вторинної
діагностики так яку ми бачимо учень і
вчитель знову отримують
вторинний діагностичне тестування
відбувається фактично за тою самою
програмою але тести будуть абсолютно
іншими і
забігаючи теж наперед було у нас питання
про авторів наших діагностичних тестів
скажу одразу таке що ми намагалися
запросити фахівців із насправді
експертів з різних тем і сфер до
прикладу У нас сьогодні є Пані Марія
блажко яка є вчителем і розуміє хто
такий учень І що є йому чи їй потрібно
я співавторкою тестового завдання також
нам важливо було мати фахівців з
освітніх оцінювань які знають як
правильно
того щоби щоби він умовно розподілив
учнів по тих рівнях які ми визначили по
4 рівнях
Шевченко він є начальником відділу
досліджень та аналітики українського
центру оцінювання якості освіти це
провідна установа яка
тестування в Україні Разом з тим нам
було Важливо пам'ятати що в нас в країні
проходить
але розробляються нові державні
стандарти та модельні навчальні програми
тут у нас присутній пан Андрій Панченко
який
державного стандарту початкової освіти
Якщо я не помиляюся пан Андрій долучався
також до
творення держав
і середньої освіти Тобто ми насправді
намагалися залучити
фахових людей для того щоб тест було
[музика]
і останнє що мушу теж зазначити
відповідно до процедури українського
інституту розвитку освіти
процедур але усі наші тести пройшли
чотири експертизи Це була
антидискримінаційна експертиза
педагогічна Наукова і психологічна Ми
висловлюємо подяку всім експертам Які
також долучалися до проведення цих
експертиз і робили Наші тести
кращими Отже я
зупиняю свою сторінку І запрошую до
слова Василя Терещенка який нам
розповість про конструювання тесту для
це були тести за цикл 3-4 класу Василь
Терещенко У нас є філолог і як я вже
сказала начальник відділу та аналітики
українського центру оцінювання якості
освіти Василю прошу
Доброго дня шановні колеги количанки які
сьогодні зібралися щоб
проговорити з нами новий інструмент який
запропонував проєкт
Я з моїми колегами буду говорити
Сьогодні про здавалося різні інструменти
тому що мій інструмент стосується третіх
четвертих класів а далі Марія там Андрій
розкажуть про інструменти для наступних
класів однак відразу зауважують що той
інструмент про який я буду говорити Він
може бути використаний як зазначала пані
Ольга і вчителькою вчителем чи
вчителькою початкових класів наприкінці
вивчення теми визначених для початкової
школи так і в 5 класі але по секрету
мабуть ви як методисти це чудово знаєте
що в деяких випадках особливо критичних
з якими ми маємо нині справу цей
інструмент може бути використаний і на
пізніше етапах то його доречно можна
буде використати і в шостому класі
наприклад на початку шостого класу або і
наприкінці шостого класу чи на початку
7-го класу залежно від ситуації
конкретної ситуації яка спостерігається
у вашому класі
і ви свій код знаєте тому безперечно
можете орієнтуватися щоб
наскільки доречним може бути цей
інструмент
поки що як сказала пані Ольга є
первинний діагностичний тестування на
сайті українського інституту розвитку
освіти і ми заходимо у відповідну
вкладку і бачимо що у нас є українська
мова п'ятий клас первинний діагностичний
тестування
спочатку коротенько про зміст який ми
закладали розробляючи
відповідний тестовий інструментарій
розробляючи його
теми які охоплені тестом є базовими
основними які на які от на яких
зосереджується увага в початкові класах
і Звісно що тут особлива увага
приділяється орфографічним темам при
цьому як в тестології є такий Принцип що
треба оцінювати
найважливіші бо всього оцінити не можна
а тим більше ми ж говоримо з вами
фактично про підсумки початкової школи
про початки п'ятого класу то діти ще не
можуть працювати занадто з довгими
тестовими інструментами Відповідно ми
дібрали для нашого тестового інструмента
теми які от особливо важливі які
допоможуть вам зрозуміти де можливо
виявляється найбільші проблеми у
відповідних знаннях і вміннях учнів Як
бачите орфограми у нас стосується
фонетики і пов'язаними
орфоепії Та пов'язаними з ними
темами орфографічними крім того увага
приділена темам збудови слова та
словотвору власне з морфем який
словотвору бо
врешті ці теми перегукуються так само з
орфографією Як бачите В орфографії У нас
є префікси і з с пре при так само Якщо
ви хочете більш цілісний уявлення
складати про те наскільки ваші учні
зрозуміли
базові речі пов'язані з будовою слова та
словотвору то вам вас можуть цікавити не
тільки відповіді дітей на ось оці
питання А так само відповіді учнів та
учениць на ось оці питання які так само
пов'язані безпосередньо з будовою слова
та словотвором крім того охоплено
тестовими інструментарієм теми з
лексикології що є дуже важливим розділом
початковій школі адже ми саме в цей
період намагаємося дітей привчити
працювати зі думками відкривати нові для
себе слова поняття це представлено в
тесті так само далі
базові речі пов'язані з морфологічними
одиницями зокрема з
повнозначними частинами мови і
незначну і мірою зі службовими частинами
мови однак Ми намагалися
збалансовано включити тестові завдання
які представили основні теми що
стосуються іменника прикметника ті на
якій ми звертаємо увагу початковій школі
і які далі поглиблено будуть вивчатися
повторюватися і вивчатися в 5-6
класах і безперечно є синтаксис і
остання тема яка так би мовити
підсумовує усе що попередньо учні
вивчають це текст розвиток мовлення так
само В нашому інструменті охоплені
засадничі речі пов'язані із цим і з цими
питаннями
відповідно до цього
змісту розроблено
три тестові частини три блоки тесту один
перша частина стосується орфографічної
вправності Як бачите на екрані написано
одне завдання насправді у цьому
тестовому інструменті ми маємо 36
завдань
36 завдань так званих завдань на вибір
відповіді зі спадного списку коли в учня
фактично є необхідність працювати з тим
як він працює в реальному житті про що
мова йде Ми всі з вами прекрасно знаємо
що орфограма традиційно визначається як
така ситуація у слові де в учня чи
особа яка пише виникає проблема тобто
виникає вибір писати Так чи писати так і
оцей інструмент який ми розробили Він
пропонує якраз от ситуацію наближену до
реальності коли Учень має стикається з
проблемою у нього написано робиться
робить ця робиться робиться і так далі
От тобі реальна життєва ситуація і учень
виконавши всі ці 36 ситуацій вибору
орфографічно він фактично
покаже вам наскільки от стикаючись із
проблемами на ситуаціями він здатиме
вирішувати їх Спираючись на свої знання
вміння навички ефективно і відповідно ви
як вчитель уважний відразу визначити де
є болючі моменти Тим більше що для вас
буде підготовлено автоматично звіт про
успішність класу а кожному учневі буде
підготовлено звіт про його успішність
другий тест субтест добірка це
завдання що стосується тексту І тут ми
увагу приділяємо в тестових завданнях
темі основній думці мікротемам не
забуваємо ми і про те що на сьогодні в
учні ми намагаємося розвивати вміння
пов'язувати поза текстові елементи
скажімо графічні картинки фотографії
тим що йдеться в тексті завдання Хоч їх
небагато однак вони передбачають дадуть
вам змогу побачити де є ще певні
труднощі у дітей під час роботи з
текстом і ми з вами прекрасно знаємо що
початковій школі читання і українська
мова це часто є один предмет
інтегрований такий курс тому ми не могли
не включити цю
субвийтест до нашої до нашої
діагностичного інструмента і
сподіваємося що він буде корисним вам
для того щоб побачити як діти працюють
із текстами і на цьому ж тексті і тут
зауважу важливий момент що орфографічна
вправність побудована на тексті потім
діти з цим самим текстом працюють коли
виконують суб вибірку другу тест другий
що стосується тексту І потім третій тест
як і ми включили мовні одиниці різних
рівнів у тексті цей тест так само
крутиться навколо того самого тексту І
це дуже важливий момент що фактично коли
учень працює з орфограмами він мав уваги
може приділяти змісту тексту однак цей
текст йому вже Буде знайомий з
попередньою діяльністю тому коли він
дійде до другого тесту що стосується
текстових одиниць він уже знатиме
загальний зміст тексту йому це спростить
певною мірою діяльністю А коли він
перейде до третього тесту мовні одиниці
різних рівнів у тексті він уже так само
тут матимемо змогу працювати з текстом
водночас цей текст для нього буде не
основним центром уваги для нього будуть
важливі окремі одиниці в межах тексту
зокрема там іменники прикметники як
правильно як неправильно і все це власне
допоможе йому і вам власне кожного разу
показувати учневі що все що ми робимо в
мові це все пов'язано із текстом текст є
центром мовної діяльності більшості
усний текст власне мовлення чи письмовий
текст і в цьому я сказав що одна з
родзинок цього інструментарію який
розроблено для початкової школи на
кінець четвертого класу для 5 класу на
початок 5-го класу або навіть на кінець
чи для шостого класу
самі завдання для інших класів покажуть
Мої колеги я сподіваюся що ви
переконаєтеся що з цими завданнями легко
доволі працювати
І вони можуть бути ефективні і ще на
останок якщо учень правильно виконує то
у звіті
інформації про це немає є тільки
кількість виконаних завдань Якщо ж учень
чи учениця помиляється при виконанні
завдання то у їхньому індивідуальному
звіті буде вказівка і буде надано певний
пол
посилань за якими учень чи учениця
можуть перейти переглянути відеоматеріал
стосовно відповідної теми і в такий
спосіб зможуть
покращити свої знання у чому ви зможете
переконатися Провівши вторинний
діагностичне тестування яке незабаром
має з'явитися
Я буду завершувати щоб не затримувати
Мої колеги далі поширять і ви побачите
деталі що стосується цього якщо будуть
питання в кінці ми на них залюбки
відповімо
пан Василю Дуже дякую але користуючись
правами модератора хотіла би поставити
запитання яке нам уже надійшло раніше
так і Яке мені здається дуже важливе є
чи замінять наші діагностичні тести
діагностувальні роботи для учнів
початкової школи і початкових класів Чи
міг би ти тут навести різкість
коли ми говоримо про діагностування яке
ми проводимо в початковій школі то в
кожного діагностування є своя певна мета
Чи це діагностування за підсумками
першого семестру третього класу 4 класу
і так далі чи це якась дослідницька мета
спеціально яку вчитель для себе ставить
і стосується ця мета певної теми
іменника прикметника чи синтаксису і
тому коли ми говоримо про цей
діагностичний інструментарій який
розроблено проєктом surge ми говоримо
про глобальніший діагностування яке
охоплює всі теми що включені для що
вивчалися впродовж початкового класів то
вчитель в думовий може це використати як
допоміжну інформацію про результати
навчання в початковій школі але говорити
що це інструмент який є офіційним
інструментом для проведення там я знаю
державної підсумкової атестації в за
підсумками четвертого класу Ні про
спрямований йде категорично тому що
державна підсумкова атестація - Це інший
інструментарій інші процедури ніж Та яку
ми зараз маємо на сайті українського
інституту розвитку освіти
Дуже дякую Василю за вичерпну відповідь
Я би хотіла представити нашого
наступного співавтора так і співтора
спікера це Андрій Панченко філолог
власне співавтор державного стандарту
початкової освіти Разом з тим креативний
директор сайту Освіта.ua Пане Андрію
Прошу і запрошую вас до слова
Вітаю Шановні колеги Дуже дякую за те що
ви знайшли часу знайомитися із нашим
інструментом Отже ми говоримо зараз про
первинний діагностичне тестування учнів
і учениці які перебувають на відповідно
певному рівні своєї загальної середньої
освіти Василь щойно розповів про
діагностичний інструмент який ми
запланували в 5 класі за
матеріалом який учні учениці опанували у
молодшій школі початковій школі я зараз
скажу кілька слів про інструмент який ми
будемо використовувати і ви зможете
використовувати у сьомому класі Отже
коли ви користуєтеся платформою
всеукраїнська школа онлайн ви можете тут
обрати
зміст для того класу який безпосередньо
вас зараз цікавить нас зараз цікавить
сьомий клас Ми його можемо вибрати і
бачимо тут
українська мова сьомий клас первинне
діагностичне тестування
так само як
і в 5 класі Ми можемо перейти і
ознайомитися з тим які теми які
тематичні блоки представлені в нашому
інструменті для учнів учениць сьомого
класу Отже відбувається діагностування і
виявлення освітніх втрат за попередні
два роки 5-6 клас Як ви пам'ятаєте
програма 5-6 класів з української мови
досить-таки строкате ми починаємо п'ятий
клас і з повторення вивченого початковій
школі далі йде
дуже багато проподактичних тем які
стосуються синтаксису які стосуються
офонетики орфоепії морфеміки словотвору
лексикології фразеології і так далі тому
ми включили у той інструмент який зараз
про який ми зараз поговоримо включили
саме
Ті теми які ми вважаємо є найбільш
показовими найбільш важливими і
засвоєння їх свідчить про те чи має
учень учениця цього освітню програму чи
треба працювати далі із цим матеріалом
чи ця тема засвоєна достатньому рівні
Отже ми взяли кілька важливих моментів
орфографії
найосновніші моменти із фонетики та
орфоепії
початкові уявлення тому що Ну звичайно
за рівень на рівні 5-6 класу ми
ознайомилися так збудовою слова
словотвором теми з лексикології
фразеології
це те що стосується переважно програми 5
класу програма шостого класу
представлена Як ви пам'ятаєте іменними
частинами мови і почина тут працювати із
дієсловом тому морфологія у нас
представлена відповідно іменником
прикметником числівником займенником
дієсловом і так далі
і синтаксис пунктуації Тобто Це ті теми
що вивчалися учнями ученицями в 5 класі
так само знайшли відображення у
завданнях окремо ми приділили по суттю
увагу текстові і розвитку мовлення
якщо ми
звернемося до
структури нашого
діагностичного тестування то побачимо що
ми що ми маємо три фактично три тести
або три частини тесту так або як кажуть
фахівці три суб тести присвячені
відповідно тексту далі програмі
переважно програмі п'ятого класу тобто
лексика орфографія і
синтаксис і третій
субтестабу третя частина тесту
присвячена морфології Тобто це переважно
програма програма нашого шостого класу
на
виконання у кожному тесті є відповідна
кількість тестових завдань тобто 20 або
наступна наступна частина пропонує 18 за
тестових завдань ще наступна частина 17
тестових завдань і ми намагалися
скорегувати цю Кількість завдань
відповідно до їхньої складності і
відповідно до того який час буде
потрібно на виконання кожного завдання
робота з текстом який присвячено першу
нашу частину тесту - Це
ось та дуже важлива частина дуже
важливої компонент наших освітніх
програм якому зараз приділяється
неабияка увага і в моніторингових
дослідженнях таких як моніторингове
дослідження якості початкової освіти в
якому ваші учні учениці брали участь і
такі
міжнародні моніторингові дослідження як
Піза яка зараз ось 22-го року відбулася
у нас
15-річні наші учасники учасниці
демонстрували свою в тому числі читацьку
компе Ось так читацького грамотність
тому ми вважаємо що окремою частиною
треба поміряти треба поміряти і
протягнустувати здатність наших
здобувачів освіти працювати з текстом
розуміти його зміст розуміти
В чому є авторський задум як це тексти
ми можемо використовувати і
аналізувати їх яким яке значення має для
тексту
заголовок під заголовки як ми за
допомогою різних засобів в тому числі не
текстових так візуальних засобів можемо
додати щось посилити і
увиразнити у те у тексті тут ми взяли те
що взяли зразок такого Ну досить-таки
оригінального тексту так званого
мішаного тексту де в нас є окремі
рубрики є окремі вставки врізки текстові
де все виділено певними шрифтами
кольорами і так далі І про це ми питаємо
тобто яким чином ми цей текст можемо
використати для чого він призначений як
ти розумієш роль такого і чи такого
слова елементу і так далі Ну я дуже тут
сильно не буду демонструвати завдання бо
ваші учні учениці будуть же ж виконувати
їх так є діагностувати себе і Ви
матимете таку змогу подивитися
наші завдання самостійно до тексту є два
два формати чи дві форми завдань це
відомі добре вам форми завдання з
вибором однієї правильно відповіді або
завдання на встановлення відповідності
Таким чином ми перевіряємо ось цю нашу
цю нашу особливу частину
[музика]
мовних комунікативних вмінь навичок
І компетент взагалі комунікативний
компетентності так і друга наша частина
- це
лексична орфографічна граматична
правильність мовлення
знайомме знайомі тут форми завдань так
само є завдання на вибір однієї
правильної відповіді і є завдання на
встановлення відповідності коли ми учень
учениця виконується завдання Він має
уважно прочитати основу вибрати один з
варіантів так і натиснути на нього щоб
позначити
той варіант відповіді який він чи вона
вважає правильним і натиснути кнопку
надіслати для того щоб система прийняла
вашу відповідь
третя частина тесту
присвячена вже безпосередньо морфології
і так само вона містить певну кількість
а саме 17 завдань на визначення
тих освітніх прогалень які могли
трапитися в наших учнів учениць під час
навчання у уже безпосередньо в шостому
класі Під час вивчення
іменника прикметника дієслова та інших
частин мови передбачених на передбачених
на уроках шостого класу
тут так само представлені завдання на
вибір одного варіанту
відповіді
правильної відповіді або завдання на
встановлення відповідності тобто так
звані
логічні пари звичні нашим учням ученицям
і за різноманітними тестовими
діагностичними і контрольними роботами і
вигідними для майбутньої підготовки до
зовнішнього незалежного оцінювання або
національного мультимедійного
мультипредметного тесту перепрошую
Отже
використовуючи наші матеріали первинного
первинного діагностичного тестування
ви можете разом зі своїми учнями
ученицями
отримати картину тобто отримати Висновок
про те що саме треба надолужити і в
підсумку як уже казав вас цей учень
учениця отримує докладний перелік тих
тем і покликання на ті матеріали
всеукраїнської школи онлайн або на
підручники з конкретними
посиланням на конкретні сторінки
конкретні параграфи
використавши які інше Вона може цієї
освітні свої прохалини надолужити а далі
вже після відповідної роботи на сайті
всеукраїнської школи онлайн буде
розміщено
вторинний вторинне тестування так
вториннедіагностичне тестування Провівши
яке можна вже робити висновки про оцю
про результативність цього повторення і
надолуження
дякую
Дякуємо вам Пане Андрію Також маю до вас
запитання яке до нас надійшло раніше
запитання буде два перше за підручниками
яких авторів складено діагностичні
роботи і друге завдання чи відрізняються
тести від уже звичних тестів ЗНО та
нмт
стосовно підручників ми виходили з того
що Наші учні учениці перебувають зараз в
надскладних умовах що є діти які
перебувають над тимчасовому окупованих
територіях є діти які перебувають за
кордоном є ті що навчаються
офлайн ті що навчаються онлайн тому ми
максимально прагнули використати
матеріали всеукраїнської школи онлайн це
переважно відео які доступні на
платформі вищого І саме за допомогою цих
матеріалів пропонуємо надолужувати ось
ці освітні втрати в окремих випадках
всеукраїнська школа онлайн ще
немає певних Ну скажімо так певних
розробок певного матеріалу який потрібен
саме для надолуження втрат щодо
конкретного завдання тому ми пропонуємо
зверну буде до підручників але ці
підручники так само є доступними на
електронній бібліотеці інституту
модернізації змісту освіти тому можна
ними користуватися
наскільки завдання діагностичного
тестування є схожими чи несхожими на ЗНО
так Правильно я зрозумів запитання
ЗНО це такий універсальний інструмент на
який
схожі всі діагностичні або контрольні
матеріали так тобто тестові завдання
мають Мають дуже широкий спектр форм
тобто на ЗНО ми використовуємо і
завдання з виборами однієї правильної
відповіді і завдання на встановлення
відповідності і послідовності відкриті
завдання тобто Звичайно що всі тестові
завдання схожі на завдання ЗНО
більше того більше до того Ми
свідомі того
ЗНО перевіряє
елементи предметної компетентності які
формуються
впродовж усіх класів так впродовж всього
шкільного курсу української мови тому
звичайно завдання на якісь стосовно там
морфології чи стосовно синтаксису яке
використовується ось в нашому
діагностичному тестуванні воно
виявиться Ну скажімо так дуже схожим на
якесь завдання на зовнішньому
незалежному оцінюванні тому що на ЗНО Ми
так само перевіряємо
знання засвоєння в сьомому класі в
шостому класі тому Звичайно так завдання
схожі і завдання допоможуть
призвичаюватися до тестового формату і
працювати із
Щоб майбутнє підготовки до зовнішнього
незалежного оцінювання Тим більше що як
ви знаєте ЗНО чи національний
мультиппредметний тест поступово
прощається з паперовою формою так
переходить до електронної форми тому
робота в електронних
оболонках з такими електронними онлайн
новими інструментами діагностування чи
контролювання є дуже і дуже корисною для
наших учнів учениць тому що Зрештою вони
в подібних онлайн нових
з подібними онлайн новими вимірювальними
інструментами будуть працювати в тому
числі і на ЗНО тому це теж це теж дуже
дуже доречно дякую Дуже дякую Пане
Андрію Василь піднімав руку пан
Васильович пані Олю я одну за увагу Хочу
додати що можливо питання колеги наших
стосувалося про підручники в той бік про
який Андрій Олексійович говорив йдеться
про те можливо вчителі мали на увазі про
те які підручники були для нас за якими
підручниками власне створено ці завдання
якій програмі навчальні відповідають ці
завдання то Якщо говорити про це й
аспект питання То варто зауважити що ми
орієнтувалися на навчальні програми так
би мовити
які будуть спільні яка спільна для всіх
програм які створені за
всіх підручників які створені на основі
державного стандарту початкової освіти
11-го року і тому власне тут немає
різниці чи це підручники пані Глазової
Чи це підручник пані там
пана Авраменка Чи це там в початковій
школі цілася мережа цих підручників ціла
сітка тому всі теми які включені до
інструментарію вони охоплені будь-яким
підручником що пропонується на сьогодні
в школі тому будь як будь-хто з вчителів
з вчительок може використовувати його
Дуже дякую пане Василю за таке уточнення
зараз хочу передати слово
згадувала Пані Марія є філологинею вона
є вчителькою української мови та
літератури у спеціалізованій школі
тріумф міста Києва і власне ми вболівали
за те щоб долучити до нашої команди
вчителів які
із учнями і
Пані Марія буде презентувати
матеріали для 9 класу але одразу Я теж
поставлю запитання яке буде таке Пані
Марія коли ви безпосередньо зі своїми
учнями так використали наші тестові
завдання коли ви провели діагностику щоб
виявити і недолучити освітні втрати чи
ваших учнів немає освітніх предків і ви
не будете вдаватися до цього інструменту
Прошу пані Марії дякую пані Олю Вітаю
Шановні колеги але хочу показати Якщо
можна то я відповідь на ваше питання
пані Олю дам в кінці
оскільки я буду говорити зараз про
дев'ятий клас і про змістове наповнення
9 класу і напевно більш доречно і
зрозуміло будемо Я відповідь тоді коли я
буду говорити вже після свого
представлення я про це питання не забуду
І обов'язково на нього відповідать А
стосовно освітніх втрат ви знаєте мені
здається вони є завжди навіть ідеальних
умовах коли ми працюємо в мирний час і
коли немає в нас ніякої пандемії все
одно діти працюють дуже по-різному і в
різних обставинах опиняються кожна
дитина і тому ці втрати На жаль завжди
можна простежувати і напевно що наше
головне завдання тільки про це пам'ятати
і дати можливість зрозуміти де ці втрати
відбулися яким чином їх надолужити і це
власне та мета яку ми зараз перед собою
і стави
Отже я буду говорити конкретніше про
дев'ятий клас так само знаходимо наш 9-й
клас на вшо заходимо
тут де можна побачити перелік тем які
ідуть в основу тестування для 9 класу ми
теж говоримо зараз про первинне
тестування
і пам'ятаємо що воно охоплює той
матеріал який вивчали Наші учні упродовж
7 класу і впродовж 8 класу і треба
сказати що на відміну іншого Іншого
курсу скажімо того курсу який закладений
в основу 7 класу тут ситуація доволі
простіша і прозоріша тому що сьомий клас
це суцільна морфологія яку завершують
вивчати учні і учениці а восьмий клас це
вже синтаксис який вивчає саме просте
речення і відповідно у тісному зв'язку
морфологія йде з орфографією а синтаксис
іде з пунктуації
і таким чином
Якщо говорити про теми які ми закладаємо
в основу нашого тестування на 9 клас
Тобто це теми за сьомий клас і за
восьмий клас то ми намагалися тут із
морфології у тісному зв'язку з
орфографією зупинитися на тих темах які
з одного боку є особливо важливими для
наступного вивчення мови у наступних
класах і з іншого боку Ті теми які
певним чином дають можливість побачити
використання безпосередньо певних
граматичних форм використання правильне
використання певних слів чи правильно
орфографічну правильність учнів а от що
стосується синтаксису і пунктуації то
звичайно що тут намагалися закласти всі
Ті теми які вивчали учнів впродовж
восьмого класу і пов'язані вони як я вже
сказала саме із прости речення для того
щоб певним чином зреалізувати наш задум
у 9 класі наше тестування передбачає
передбачає три тести
зараз я
передбачаю три тести так як це було і в
інших класах перший тест називається
морфологічно вправність мовлення другий
тест - це діагностичне тестування з
граматики і третій тест якраз передбачає
тестування діагностичне і синтаксису
зокрема курс простого речення саме про
ці три тести Я зупинюся трішки
докладніше і
виходячи із того що Ми планували
перевірити нашим тестуванням ми
відповідно прив'язали наші тестування до
різних форм завдань Таким чином перший
тест чи субтест морфологічна вправність
мовлення дозволяє нам перевірити яким
чином засвоїли учні норми морфології
Тобто це всі теми починаючи від дієслова
включно із формами дієслова
дієприкметник дієприслівник далі прислів
службові частини мови вигук і таким
чином намагалися ми показати це у
конкретному вже практичному використанні
про яке говорив пан Василь Отже в цьому
тесті перед нами 41 завдання на яке ми
рекомендуємо відвести 30 хвилин і всі ці
завдання пов'язані із єдиним типом
завдань Тобто це вибрати правильну
відповідь із отакого випадного списку
який трапляється на кожному кроці
відповідно 41 прогалину треба заповнити
і тільки тоді коли учні запомнять
абсолютно всі пропуски Вони мають
можливість перечитати свій текст із
таким заповненням який вони яке вони
пропонують і тоді скористатися цією вже
кнопочкою надіслати і отримати свій
результат
які безпосередньо теми закладені в цю
морфологічну вправність мовлення Як я
вже сказала ця тема пов'язані з дуже
практичним використанням Чи письмом це
зокрема теми на правильні граматичні
форми дієслів з різних
починаючи від дійсного способу
закінчуючи наказовим Це правильне
вживання дієприкметників дієприслівників
це правопис прислівників Це
розпізнавання
прислівників сполучників та співзвучних
чи однозвучних і з ними слів особливо де
це відображається певним чином на
написанні різному скажімо про те треба
написати разом чи треба написати окремо
і так далі
крім того тут можна простежити наскільки
учні вміють доречно використовувати
прийменники що є однією із таких
важливих тем у вивченні прийменника і
зрозуміло що 41 завдання дозволяє мати
перед собою досить чітку картину що 41
завдання дозволяє мати перед собою
досить чітку картину другий тест який
пов'язаний вже із морфологією з
дієсловом прислівником службовими
частинами мови містить безпосередньо
тестові завдання таких тестових завдань
у другій частині ми маємо 15 і вони вже
дуже наближені до такого формату завдань
які є на ЗНО чи не МТ тобто 13 завдань
це завдання на вибір однієї правильної
відповіді із чотирьох і два завдання -
це завдання на встановлення
логічних пар
на цих 15 завдань ми рекомендуємо
використовувати час 30 хвилин і третя
частина яка вже переводить нас до з цих
містить
20 завдань це завдання всі пов'язані вже
з синтаксисом і пунктуацією тому тут
можна знайти завдання пов'язані із
розстановкою правильних розділових
знаків
починаючи від однорідних членів речення
і закінчуючи різними ускладненими
компонентами скажімо там
відокремленими членами речення вставними
словами звертаннями і так далі І серед
тих 20 завдань Ми також маємо завдання
яке є на вибір однієї правильної
відповіді таких завдань 16 і 4 завдання
це завдання на встановлення
відповідності тобто на логічні фари Я
впевнена що якщо
провести це тестування таким чином яким
був у нас задум тобто із докладним
виявленням прогалем прогалин у вивченні
тієї чи іншої теми то насправді ми
будемо мати дуже прозору картину і
зрозуміле поле для нашої діяльності на
перспективу Це так коротко що стосується
9 класу а тепер я хочу повернутися до
того питання яке мені поставила Пані Оля
на початку коли доречно такі тестування
проводити насправді мені здається що
вчитель тут вже може сам зорієнтуватися
і зрозуміти коли доречно що проводити бо
Наприклад якщо безпосередньо брати мене
то я уявляю собі що я можу провести це
тестування не тільки так як попередньо в
нас був задум на початку 9-го класу щоб
виявити прогалини за сьомий восьмий клас
чи на початку 7 класу Я це тестування
можу провести наприклад напри 8 класу і
наприкінці восьмого класу Я можу
перевірити як те що учні вже вивчили у 7
класі і те що учні вивчили у восьмому
класі а можу наприкінці восьмого класу
взяти лише те що стосується восьмого
класу і провести цей тест який
пов'язаний суто із синтаксисом простого
речення точно так само я можу взяти
наприкінці сьомого класу лише перший
субтест і перевірити чи з'ясувати
морфологічну вправність моїх учнів чи
якщо я захочу побачити якісь не тільки
суто практичні навички але якісь важливі
теоретичні засади які потім мені
знадобляться для 8 чи 9 класу то
звичайно що я можу наприкінці сьомого
класу використати і другий субтест тобто
якщо вникнути в ці питання і зрозуміти
їхню суть то я впевнена що кожен вчитель
вже далі може користуватися тим ресурсом
так як буде Вважати за потрібне і як
йому буде найзручніше і найдоцільніше
дякую Дуже дякую пані Марії І за
представлення інструменту і за відповідь
тут Пані Марія дуже доцільно згадала що
насправді наш тест складається наприклад
з трьох частин і кожну частину можна
використовувати окремо незалежно від
двох інших так і з цією частиною
Наприклад ми зробили діагностичне
тестування і працюємо лише з цією
частиною тобто вчитель не зобов'язаний
задавати так учням одразу три частини А
ще інша особливість і мені здається
величезна перевага нашого діагностичного
тестування що учень отримає результат
або звіт за кожну частину так тобто йому
не потрібно проходити
це тоді отримати звіт за кожну частину
окремо а після проходження лише однієї з
них він також
Дуже дякую пані Маріє зараз передаю
слово нашим колегам з українського
інституту розвитку освіти які дуже довго
з нами співпрацювали
ми мали багато побажань щодо
розвитку так функціоналу
всеукраїнської школи онлайн Я дякую
паніні так само Дякую її колегам пану
Юрію ковальчуку які дослухалися до всіх
працювали разом з нами Отже запрошую
пані Ніну та її колегу пані Алли
ворожбит представити те
безпосередньо можуть організувати таке
тестування на сайті всеукраїнської школи
онлайн Отже ні на Слюсаренко начальник
сектору їх ресурсів українського
інституту розвитку освіти а також пані
Алла ворожбит методистка сектору
освітніх ресурсів українського центру
розвитку освіти Колеги вам слово
Вітаю Шановні колеги всіх хто доєднався
до сьогоднішнього вебінару і всіх хто
буде дивитися нас потім у записі
Сьогодні ми з вами дізнаємося як власне
організувати комп'ютерне тестування
вимірювання освітніх втрат які можна
буде здійснити на платформі вшо
власне
Я знаю що далеко ще не всі вчителі
зареєструвалися на платформі а тому я
пару слів Можу сказати про
цю освітню платформу всеукраїнська школа
онлайн
вона створена для
дистанційного та змішаного навчання і
зараз на платформі розміщені
предмети розміщені уроки для
десятих з 5 по 11 клас власне Ми
плануємо
невдовзі вже зробити і уроки для
початкової школи наразі поки що да 5-11
клас ага
[музика]
власне
а власне Кожен урок у нас складається
з
відеокомпоненту
відеокомпонент
тривалістю від 5 до 15 хвилин також є
конспект і
тестові завдання тестові завдання у нас
ідуть до кожного уроку і
так же у нас передбачено тематичне
тестування і в кінці кожного курсу у нас
є
тестування річне
ці освітні матеріали будуть корисні для
і для учнів для тих хто займається
дистанційною для тих хто зараз
тимчасово перебуває за кордоном чи на
окупованих територіях Ну і для вчителів
які
готуються до
для підготовки до уроку для проведення
змішаного навчання
Ну також я хотіла сказати що
станом на листопад
2022 року на платформі вже зареєстрована
понад 300 тисяч учнів і понад
понад
1300 тисяч вчителів також десь близько
30 тисяч слухачів ну власне для тих хто
не зареєстрований на платформі Я хотіла
би підкреслити важливість реєстрації
тому що от що стосується тестів то
власне без реєстрації ви ці тести не
можете не побачити не пройти не
переглянути запитання тому да цей цей
момент реєстрації дуже важливий
реєстрація насправді не складна А зараз
ви можете побачити
цю форму реєстрації
можна ввести свою електронну пошту ім'я
прізвище ім'я користувача І власне було
б дуже добре якщо би ваші учні
використовували свій
речовини акаунт акаунт при реєстрації
тому що він тоді буде
дуже коректно відображатися вже в
журналі оцінювання
Далі ви дізнаєтесь власне як створити
власний курс первинного діагностичного
тестування як запросити учнів учениць
для курсу ми вас ознайомимо з
інструкцією до тестування І власне ви
зможете побачити звіти з виявлення
освітніх
освітніх втрат і дізнатися як можна
надолужити прогалини у знаннях І вміннях
учнівства
власне зараз я хотіла би
[музика]
представити свою передати слово своїй
колезі Алі ворожби
Доброго дня
Вітаю всіх учасників вебінару Дякую
паніні дякую пані Ользі щиро хочу
подякувати від себе всім хто долучився
до створення такого прекрасного
інструмента ми зможемо виміряти дійсно
чітко і професійно освітні втрати у
наших учнів тому що дійсно до яких би
умов діти би наші не навчалися Можливо
вони трапляються так і далі ми з вами
перейдемо безпосередньо до того як же
нам здійснити таке комп'ютерне
тестування на платформі всеукраїнської
школи онлайн для цього ми з вами
розглянемо такі інструменти як кабінет
вчителя на платформі української школи
онлайн
так видно мою презентацію так
коли ви загинулися на платформі ви
можете потрапити в кабінет вчителя це
інструмент
створений для спільної роботи учнів та
учениць для відстеження їхнього прогресу
на платформі всеукраїнської школи онлайн
Коли ми залагинулися ви можете обрати
вкладку Мій кабінет і потрапити на
перший пункт меню інструкція тут ви
можете ознайомитися з невеличким відео
відео інструкція як користуватися
Кабінетом вчителя після того як ви це
зробите
позначте будь ласка поставте позначку
про те що ви уважно опрацювали
інструкцію
і Натисніть на кнопку розпочати відео
буде доступне і надалі якщо у вас
виникнуть якісь питання ви можете до
нього теж звертатися наступним кроком
буде створення копії вашого власного
курсу для цього необхідно перейти до
пункту меню запросити учнів та учениць
на курс так і обрати клас обрати предмет
українська мова і відповідно первинна
діагностичне тестування і натиснути
кнопку готову далі буде відбуватися
копіювання нашого курсу це може зайняти
певний час тому слід трохи почекати коли
копіювання буде готово ви зможете
побачити вже створений курс на третій в
платті цього меню управління курсами ось
ми бачимо У нас є створена алгебра
дев'ятий клас математика п'ятий клас
тобто за потреби Що вам потрібно
наступним кроком буде
запрошення учнів та учениць на нашому
платформу для цього їх необхідно
зареєструвати Я би рекомендувала
спочатку зареєструвати учнів на самій
платформі всеукраїнської школи онлайн
для цього учні можуть обирати свої
облікові шкільні записи для того щоб
вони не змішувалися з їхніми приватними
особистими даними а перелік таких коштів
ви можете внести
у віконечку яке у вас з'явиться через
кому їх можна назвати сам список можна
буде отримати у адміністратора
шкільних акаунтів це може бути наприклад
адміністратор Google workspace або
класного керівника того класу і
натискаєте зареєструвати на курс
після того
учнів необхідно розділити по класам ви
можете натиснути на вкладці класи додати
клас можна створити назву нашого класу
це може бути наприклад з вами створювали
5 клас нехай це буде 5
-а клас і натискаєте створити
так після того як ви створили цей клас
ви можете надіслати запрошення учням У
вас є скопійовані їхні облікові записи і
натиснути кнопку додати учні Таким чином
отримують запрошення і запрошення буде
виглядати як на слайді на зображені
праворуч після того вони зможуть
доєднатися до класу
ви їх можете
додати вже в класі це є показала
в наступному слайді ви бачите курс як
він буде виглядати в кабінеті учня хочу
звернути увагу що сам курс буде
розміщений на вкладці курси від вчителів
вчителів саме за таких умов ви як
вчитель зможете побачити звіт по кожному
учню і для класу Загалом якщо би зробили
розподіл по класам тому що якщо учень
просто прийде цей курс курс нашого то
результати відображатимуться лише його
особистому кабінеті і йому буде
необхідно завантажити pdf файл для того
щоб його вам не дійшла але для загальної
статистики зручно все ж таки зібрати
дітей в класі і побачити загальну
картину по дітям і як далі планувати
діяльність з учнями на наступному слайді
ви бачите структуру слайдів так
структуру самих тестів про них уже
детально розказали Пані Марія пан Василь
та пан Андрій Я на цьому зупинятися не
буду так після того
як учні Ви впевнені що вони точно
зареєструвалися на платформі
всеукраїнської школи онлайн
переконайтесь що вони зареєстровані в
курсі і тоді Запропонуйте учням Пройти
тестування коли учні оберуть один із
тестів перед ними буде представлена
інструкція з не можуть ознайомитися вони
дізнаються Що наприклад
у питаннях можна обрати одну правильну
відповідь обов'язково після здійснення
вибору цієї відповіді необхідно
натискати кнопку надіслати якщо учень
Хоче змінити не завершивши тест-
відповідь обрати іншу він може це
зробити але обов'язково повторно
натиснути на вкладку надіслати
тести по часу на самій платформі
всеукраїнської школи онлайн не обмежень
час може контролювати вчитель Ну а саме
тестування можна проводити як в класі це
може бути комп'ютерний клас або якщо у
вашому кабінеті української мови є
мобільні якісь планшети чи комп'ютери
можна провести його прямо в закладі
освіти також можна
протестувати дітей коли вони будуть
знаходитися вдома звичайно
далі після того як ви
провели тестування ми можемо переглянути
журнал оцінок для цього ви можете
перейти на вкладку в моєму кабінеті
управління курсом і оцінювання
натискаєте переглянути журнал оцінок і
буде представлено ось таке табличка з
результатами
кожного учня для того щоб побачити
успішність ви обираєте ім'я у стовпчику
ліворуч і бачите результати його
діяльності Учні не отримають оцінки
взяті тести тестах Лише буде показано
рівень досягнень від початкового до
високого в даному випадку в мене були
учні які протестували зі мною цю
платформу це справжні учні 9 класу
реальні спочатку Звичайно вони показали
успішні результати Я вже потім
наступного учня попросила зробити вже
свідомо якусь помилку для того щоб
подивитися як же це буде виглядати і ось
уже учні послухали і ось у нас є учень
який припустився свідомо помилок це не
завадило йому отримати результат
високого рівня Але у цьому
індивідуальному звіті ми бачимо наступну
вкладочку прогалини тобто відповідно до
теми в мене зараз на жаль математику
учні приходили ви бачите результати з
математики і ми бачимо що учень Отримав
повідомлення про те що він не впорався з
завданнями і він може
краще ти результати в цьому напрямі
ознайомившись з відеофрагментом на
платформі всеукраїнської школи онлайн в
даному випадку це у нас буде алгебра
тема про рівняння і ось сьомий клас
лінійна функція відео можна переглянути
як на платформі YouTube Так і
безпосередньо уже в курсі всеукраїнської
школи онлайн
також є покликання на підручники для
зазначених параграф і сторінка з якими
необхідно ознайомитися а також
вправи які учні можуть виконати
крім індивідуального звіту можна
сформулювати
звіт по класу в даному випадку я
поділила учні з 9-а класу Олени і якщо я
натисну кнопку завантажити звіт для 9
класу У мене були сформовані файл в
форматі
електронних таблиць Я зараз покажу на
слайді Як він виглядає фрагмент цього
документу тут уже зазначені ті прогалини
які були виявлені під час тестування
учнями конкретного класу за значенням
тем і відповідно знов же відеофрагментів
та
завдань з підручника які необхідно учням
опрацювати
після того коли ці теми будуть
надолужені буде можливим
виконати Завдання вторинного
діагностичного тестування яке також буде
завантажено розміщено на платформі
всеукраїнської школи онлайн
переконані що робота з таким
діагностичним комп'ютерним тестуванням з
української мови для учнів 5-7 та 9
класу на платформі всеукраїнської школи
онлайн буде сприяти
покращення успішності учнів та утримання
ними вже хороших позитивних оцінок
справжньому журналі дякую
Дякуємо пані Алло
зі своїми учнями безпосередньо працювала
Я скажу що я коли тестила ці завдання і
так само звіт як він працює Я працювала
з
навіть Дехто з них був за кордоном і
якою помилки я допустилася і я не
сказала учням що вони мають проходити
тест саме той до якого я їх запросила я
стати які є Так А потім сказала пройдіть
їх значить в мене було 10 учнів всі
сказали що прийшли тест а інформацію я
маю лише по семи учнях і я не могла
зрозуміти
якась трапилося так мені мама або учень
присилає звіт що він тест пройшов але
його немає в моєму звіті як звіті
вчителя І лише тоді я зрозуміла що ці
учні або батьки допомогли учням вони
пройшли курс Так але не той до яких я їх
запросила тому тут паняла на тому вже
дуже акцентувала я просто додатково хочу
підкреслити що Якщо ви будете
запрошувати своїх учнів до курсу ТО
справді Прослідкуйте щоб це був саме Ваш
курс до
оскільки ви одразу отримаєте усю
інформацію і тут пані але я не знаю чи є
були у вас інші графіки в Львівському
файлі Так але
ті які отримувала я то я бачила перелік
прізвищ учнів так які
на початковому рівні А є ті які на
базовому центрі пані Ольга Так це в
екселівському Пані там є статистика по
тесту Тобто там має бути Крива Крива
нормального розподілу з відповідями
учнів і відповідно вже аналіз
дистракторів по питанням які там є Тобто
це можна в екселівському парі
ознайомитися я лише акцентувала увагу на
останній вкладці Я хочу підкреслити
власне що зручність такого звіту полягає
в тім що ви одразу отримаєте інформацію
про тих учнів з якими вам точно потрібно
працювати бо вони виконали завдання поки
що на початковому рівні так і це може
зробити там двоє учнів
Я не знаю може бути і пів класу Тоді вам
треба буде
без з'ясовувати яка це була саме тема
морфологія синтаксис пунктуація чи
можливо якась інша так І власне дивитися
на ті рекомендації які ми підготували чи
то переглянути відео чи попрацювати
А є звичайно учні які виконують завдання
на високому рівні їм така додаткова
підтримка буде не потрібною можливо цей
інструмент спочатку виглядає дещо
марудним але насправді так не є тобто
якщо ви спробуєте так і перший раз
зареєструєтеся і зареєструєте своїх
учнів я
вам вдасться вдасться і провести
тестування і отримати звіт Але я думаю
що Оскільки ми лише вперше так
запускаємо роботу таку-то і якщо у вас
би були якісь зауваження так чи
застереження то що до роботи я маю на
увазі функціонал А про це повідомляти і
нам і певного колегам з української
інституту розвитку освіти Ми будемо
робити все для того щоб
такі завдання і цей інструмент виконував
свою роль
наскільки мені говорять Мої колеги ми не
маємо додати питання принаймні зараз так
виглядає що ми відповіли на всі або
вчителям Треба якийсь час для того щоб
ознайомитися з інструментом і Можливо
тоді в них виникнуть більш такі
предметні більш предметні запитання ми
причини Я пропоную
закінчувати наш вебінар хіба можливо
нашим авторам спала якась думка впродовж
цього часу і вони хочуть її з нами
поділитися нею
пан Василь
має одну за увагу що ми говорили про
первинний діагностичний діагностичний
інструмент А про вторинний тільки
згадували що він буде оприлюднений і так
далі І тут важливо Вчительську розуміти
що вторинний діагностичний інструмент це
значною мірою дзеркало первинного тобто
якщо ви побачите прогалини якісь під час
первинного тестування що там не знають
префікса при пре скажімо то ця сама тема
обов'язково буде включена і у вторинний
діагностичне тестування і відповідно
Якщо там буде проблема То значить є
якась більш
глобальна проблема очевидно з префіксом
пре при і в цьому теж особливість нашого
інструмента що інструментарію точніше що
ми намагалися от
простежити щоб вчитель мав можливість
простежити з результатами і
результативність роботи з надолуження у
часі і відповідно отримати оці зрізи які
допоможуть вас ним От бачите якісь ну
об'єктивні речі тут мені йдеться про
суб'єктивізм з боку вчителя або є
інструмент є його результати і є робота
учня або немає роботи учня
то така думаю важлива заувага для нашого
вчительства
як я вже згадувала але зараз трохи
детальніше
зараз на сайті вийшов оприлюднені тести
для первинного діагностичного тестування
орієнтовно в лютому будуть оприлюднені
тести для вторинної діагностики як я вже
казала ми це робимо навмисне
не кортіло чим швидше перевірити себе
вдруге бо дуже часто ми сприймаємо тести
як Ну так попробувати Так а можливо я
з іншим тестом вже справлюся краще
насправді ж наша діагностика передбачає
оцей
півторамісячний період коли учні і
вчителі мають попрацювати так вони мають
опрацювати разом ті прогалини які були
виявлені в результаті первинної
діагностики І лише потім Приступити до
результатів до тестування і відповідно
отримати результати вторинної
діагностики тому вторинна діагностика
буде вона вже є але ми її просто не
відкриваємо на сайті вишила але буде
дещо пізніше бо ми все ж таки
розраховуємо
проведете тестування і пропрацюєте з
учнями безпосередньо Також я хотіла би
ще сказати що насправді можливо нас
дивляться не лише вчителі а вчителі
мають і своїх дітей
наш інструмент насправді передбачений що
його можуть застосовувати не лише
цілий клас А Кожен учень може самостійно
ним скористатися зараз дуже багато дітей
так перебувають на сімейній формі
навчання тобто вчаться вдома
індивідуально Я думаю що для них це
інструмент також є вкрай
для того щоб розуміти з чим варто
попрацювати надалі щоб його надолужити
також На завершення хочу сказати що це
перший вебінар другий вебінар
присвячений
математиці відбудеться через тиждень
17 січня Так само о 14
ми до цього вебінару запросили
авторів які розробляли тестові завдання
з математики також Але дещо Пізніше
будемо мати окремий вебінар для вчителів
початкової школи Оскільки ми маємо тести
для п'ятого класу вони будуть за курс
3-4 класу а це два предмети і математика
і українська мова то десь ближче до
весни ми проведемо такий спільний
вебінар спільний тобто з авторами і
математиками І філологами власне
безпосередньо для вчителів початкової
школи Сьогодні ми більш щоб вебінари на
вчителів
базової середньої школи Так але буде
окремо вебінар для для вчителів
початкової школи ну але як я вже сказала
буде дещо пізніше
якщо Мої колеги і співвтори нічого не
хочуть додати питань ми додаткових немає
Я дуже дякую пані Марії пан Василю Пане
Андрію колегам з української
Алі за те що долучилися Ми дуже
сподіваємося що ми зацікавили вчителів
так застосовувати цей інструмент я дякую
тут пані Марії яка насправді відкрила що
цим інструментом можна користуватися не
лише в тих насправді класах виявляється
як ми собі думали п'ятий сьомий і
дев'ятий А також розподіляти його
частинами і можна використовувати
допустим так і в шостому і в сьомому
класі і в восьмому Якщо я правильно
зрозуміла пані Марію Отож він такий дуже
флексибол так і його можна як у цього
слона їсти частинки використовувати
частими Пані Марія включила мікрофон
хоче щось сказати
Так я просто хотіла сказати що я Власне
цей мала на увазі пані Олю що ви
говорили що задум спочатку був один
вихід тільки на 5-7 і 9-й клас але в
процесі роботи склалося так Як склалося
і склалося на дуже добрий формат який
тепер в принципі якщо так казати на
загал то може покрити абсолютно всю
всю Ланку від 5 навіть від кінця 4 до
початку 9-го класу ну на вихід після 9
класу тому ще нічого не маємо
Але це вже Маленький хвостик залишився
із тих матеріалів то
Так це правда ми
плануємо працювати і надалі так тому
Слідкуйте за повідомленнями на сайті чи
в соціальних мережах української
інституту розвитку
формувати щодо того як ми будемо
працювати і розвиватися далі Сьогодні я
дуже Всім дякую і пропоную завершувати
наш вебінар
дякую